this is a production of cornell
university
all right come on in folks you can come
closer to me you're welcome to check out
the plants you're welcome to check out
the soil as well
i'm going to start
so first i want to talk about what is a
high tunnel i don't think we haven't
given that enough attention a high
tunnel is a greenhouse but it's a
greenhouse that sits on soil
why would we do this why would we grow
cannabis indoors
well inside of a high tunnel so this is
a marriage between field production
and greenhouse production fully
automated greenhouse production so what
i'm going to share with you reflects off
of some of what our economic speaker had
this morning john hancher
as well as
our greenhouse speaker neil matson
shared around
fertility in a soilless setting this is
a soil setting
so
how about
comments from the crowd why would i grow
this inside
in the soil any ideas
a lot easier easier than say hydroponics
it seems easier that's the comment up
front anything else why else would i
grow this inside yeah
light and what was the first thing
free sunlight and so that's one of the
biggest things in agriculture if we're
going to spend money on any input
whether that's a tractor a fertilizer
injector
a bag of fertilizer or a greenhouse we
have to ask ourselves
what does that input provide for us over
field production
so high tunnel production provides a
couple advantages over field production
one of those is earliness so we can
plant indoors
a crop like
hemp probably two to four weeks earlier
than we would plant it outdoors
so something that's photo sensitive in
other words responds to the length of
day
getting it in earlier when in this part
of the world our days are longer
earlier we're going to probably have
more branching and more foliar
biomass our total yield is going to be
higher
any other reasons we grow inside keep
the water off at the end of the year
keep the keep the water that's a great
idea so now i've got a rain cover which
is a good thing also has some challenges
with it
at harvest time
i could also probably skate through
a frost or two in the fall maybe i can
pick up two to four more weeks in the
fall by growing indoors
anything else come to mind
that that issue of input cost
that's something i would really
encourage you to think about in terms of
the benefit you're getting from the crop
relative to the investment that you're
putting into it compare that to field
production compare that to greenhouse
production compare that to the grow dome
that we're going to look at at one point
and then you can begin to make decisions
on what you're going to do
those are some of the benefits of
growing inside
i think in all likelihood we're probably
going to increase our total cannabinoid
production by growing indoors on a per
space unit
since we are excluding rain we have to
think about the condition of the soil
so if everyone looks at the soil
they've done a great job savannah's done
a great job of
almost getting rid of all our weeds in
here we've got this open space between
plants
can you folks see some white residue on
the surface
you can reach down and pick some of that
up
any ideas on what this is
lime this is correct salt that's also
correct
so since we don't have any rain in here
we have no leaching natural leaching of
this soil with rain or snow over time
and certain uh inputs tend to build up
over time one of them is calcium and if
you remember from neal's talk this
morning
most groundwater in upstate new york is
high in calcium and it really is
dissolved lime
so
cannabis needs calcium that's not a
problem
but too much of a good thing is not a
good thing and so what we find is as
these levels build up over time other
nutrients are restricted uh particularly
phosphorus and potassium in
inside of high tunnels so
managing a high tunnel soil first and
foremost we've got to think about how
are we going to address
that issue of
of calcium in the soil in the water any
thoughts on that
neil gave the answer this morning
lower the ph how do you lower that ph
yep sulfuric acid if you're interested
in a more organic approach a citric acid
which is a slightly
weaker acid is the is the asset of
choice for organic production
while we're talking about organic
production
you cannot grow hemp
in a organic sense in a hydroponic
setting
to be organic your crops need to be in
the soil so this is one of the primary
advantages of a high tunnel it allows us
to be organic but we receive a lot of
these benefits of the greenhouse
structure
this high tunnel doesn't have any heat
in it
we could put heat in here too if we
wanted to and still call it a high
tunnel that'd be just fine
okay so we're going to address calcium
by adding um some acid
we also want to think about this soil
as our primary
bank of nutrients or how
that was going to deliver nutrients to
our crop in the system that neil showed
this morning
we're able to pulse out nutrients in a
parts per million manner to that
hydroponic crop in a greenhouse
beginning maybe we're at 150 parts per
million in and then we creep up to 200
and then we back down to maybe 150 100
ppm nitrogen
we can take that same approach here in a
high tunnel that's perfectly okay
the the plant has the same needs
however we have to look at what else are
we putting in with that nitrogen
so if that nitrogen is coming in an
organic form is there phosphorus with
that is there potassium with that is
there calcium with that and if i'm
chasing nitrogen at a high level
to get the biggest bushiest plant i can
am i over applying those other nutrients
there's a very good chance you are
so growing in a high tunnel the first
thing you want to do is test your soil
there's a number of labs that can can
help you with that soil test once i get
that soil test back i'm looking at
nitrogen phosphorus potassium magnesium
calcium and our micronutrients then i
can make adjustments to those if i don't
take those
those those levels and i continue to
fertilize this crop to get my maximum
yield i'm probably going to over apply
something that's not a problem in year
one
it's generally not problem year two by
year three we have excess levels of
certain nutrients like phosphorus
magnesium and calcium that begin to
restrict yield
and we decrease the longevity of the
high tunnel so we want a soil test
that's extremely important
neil also shared this morning that there
are labs now with sufficiency ranges for
our foliage root units
so after we've taken a soil test we can
now do full air sampling throughout the
season to make sure that we're staying
within
the sufficiency range for the plant in
other words how good a job are we doing
providing a fertilizer to this crop and
how good a job is the plant doing to
take it up ph is
as noted earlier is probably the most
critical factor there
so testing we test our soil we test our
plant
one more thing we need to test and i'm
not talking about the flowers
that's our water we have to have a water
test as well primarily looking at ph and
and dissolve calcium or calcium
bicarbonate when i have those three
tests i can begin to formulate a
fertilizer program
if i want to do this in an organic
fashion
i'm probably going to front load that
fertility in other words i'm going to
fit this soil in the spring
and i'm going to apply
those nutrients early on because i have
less soluble nutrients available to me
if i'm going to grow this with
conventional fertilizers i can spoon
feed these crops just like they do in
hydroponics with smaller doses
throughout the season injecting it
through this drip line that you see
right here
i'm gonna go to questions comments
thoughts
yeah up front uh do you amend these beds
at all with anything before you put it
in do we amend these beds with anything
at all before we put the crop in we
should
we take a soil test and we should amend
based on any deficiencies we find in the
soil ahead of time i don't know if
savannah can hear me or is in
so i would ask savannah if she did amend
these or not
she's too far away but i wouldn't
consider the second one would you
consider this a living soil would i
consider this a living soil
i consider most soil living and so
you're hitting on an important point
here which is the microbial health of
the
of the soil and again a major difference
between hydroponic production
and high tunnel production is this soil
and the nutrients that we may apply
there in a chemical sense depend on
a microbial really a whole ecosystem
there to mediate that transfer of
nutrients into the root system so if
it's not living i'm basically in
hydroponics even though i'm in the soil
savannah did you want to tell us what
you amended with
yeah i believe it was
19
5 or 4 19 5 or 4
are 19 i can't remember if it was 19
five or four but um at 100 pounds of in
per acre and then you'll notice some of
the plots like this but have a big white
hinge to them that's because we apply
velocity which is
a silicon crystal to the soil to try to
control the pattern we'll do and i'll be
talking more about why we did that later
on
that's not calcium that's one of your
treatments
okay
there's my timer
[Music]
so one of the things we do in high
tunnels uh to maintain that microbial
life that was mentioned up here in the
front is that we promote cover cropping
in the wintertime and i have a research
program around that so once these plants
come out of here we could sew a cover
crop a legume or a grain
allow that to grow in the cooler months
and then incorporate that and there in a
sense we're feeding our microbes and
ideally providing some long-term
fertility to the crop
if you go to the ocm webpage you'll
notice that they strongly encourage
cultivators to use organic practices
so if you're strongly encouraged by osm
to use organic practices how are you
going to do that in a hydroponic setting
you don't have to answer me just think
about it
deep water culture okay
any other comments or thoughts
questions
what are your handles
what are my handles
oh yeah i'm at judd reed
judy jud reid
i just tweeted out that
reid is giving sage advice you have to
follow him thank you
that means i'm getting old if i'm sage
yeah
now
yes another comment here
yeah
so these high tunnels the question is
about orientation and on the compass
we're talking about here what i would
suggest is generally orienting on a
north-south
orientation
this crop is growing in the time of year
where we want this the sun is pretty far
north as far north as it gets in new
york and if we are north south
the sun's going to go overhead and you
have no fixed shadows each one of these
overhead supports if this was oriented
east-west in a sense becomes a fixed
shadow if the sun is traveling directly
overhead east-west so north-south on a
single bay like this that's my
suggestion
do we ever move them
yeah these things do get moved and there
are versions with with wheels um there's
a manufacturer called rimmel rmol
that
that will sell you those
my experiences so if we move them you
get away from the soil problems that i'm
talking about
those models do tend to move sometimes
in directions we don't want them to go
they're a little bit less fixed to the
ground but if you do move it you can
maintain soil health easier move it
every couple years
yes
in the back
uh there's a gentleman behind you and
then you
yeah
um
yeah so a comment on removing the
plastic removing the plastic does allow
a winter's worth of precipitation to
come in that's great it's very hard on
the plastic to do that
most greenhouse plastic really is it
comes with a three-year
usable life now
if you're farmers when i say three
you're hearing four and some of you are
hearing the word five
what i would suggest is at the end of
those three years that's the time to
remove the plastic and give it that full
season of leaching the second question
was or comment was about compost
compost does a couple of things for us
it is an organic sense of new source of
nutrients and beyond nutrients it also
provides
some carbon for soil life and it
provides physical structure to the soil
as well
most compost does not have a balanced
set of nutrients in terms of what we're
looking for so if someone is going to
use compost
as their source of nitrogen their sole
source of nitrogen they're going to
grossly over apply other nutrients and
you get away with it for a year or two
but not not much beyond that
yes there was a go ahead do you know
what the psi is in here or how long or
how often
the psi in the drip line savann you want
to do that or you want me to do it good
um i believe we have a pressure
system it's at 10 psi and we had to do a
lot of
fiddling around with the irrigation
system in here just so we weren't over
watering and i'll talk a bit more about
that later on today but we irrigate this
for 15 minutes three times a day at this
point every eight hours
and that's seeming to work well for us
[Applause]
yeah so janice has a question in regards
to compost that might have a a lot of
wood chips in it
those wood chips are basically carbon
and it's great to get carbon into the
soil once that carbon goes into the soil
the microbes that are there
generally want to break that down
when they do that they're going to
compete with our plants particularly for
nitrogen so over applying woody compost
can lead to a nitrogen deficiency in
your crop
that's the short answer on that
yes
you said three times a day for 15
minutes i know some plants benefit more
from
kind of drying right out
heavy watering
is that true with hemp or do they prefer
smaller
more dispersed water
do you want to do that savannah you want
me to do it
yeah
you're still still working it out i
actually would disagree with with their
approach of going every 15 minutes
in
three times a day
plants don't need
water at night uh plants need
water most when they're under
photosynthetic stress so in other words
what is their peak workload during the
day
that's about one o'clock in the
afternoon so for me i would approach a
more thorough watering
probably mid-morning with the following
rationale
if i can apply water to a greater depth
of this soil profile i'm going to
promote deeper rooting if that plant
roots deeper it's more likely to access
some of those hard to get micronutrients
and other macronutrients that i might be
struggling to get
that's me i don't have a lot of science
behind that that's that's just my
experience yes i was wondering the same
thing about the water and watering at
night does that promote powdery mildew
does watering at night promote powdery
mildew
i don't know but there's no good reason
to water at night i'll say that yeah
yeah
yeah please do chris smart
powdery mildew unlike all other diseases
like dry leaves but high humidity so if
you water at night you're going to get
you're going to bump up the humidity
when the air is cooler and your it can
absolutely promote uh powder building
but i agree there's no good reason to
water at night
well
um
it's almost 12 o'clock some of you may
be hungry i'm hungry
there was a question about my my handles
on social media
it's judd reed t-d-r-e-i-d
in front of a little yellow tree
like a yellow tree yeah tree that's not
me that's the other juggery there's a
guy he's in he's like in a rock and roll
band that's not me
i have professional accounts on facebook
and twitter like instagram is like pure
rainbows kittens and sailboats you're
welcome to follow me there that's my
personal page
i think we should wrap this up um
is there an organizer present that's
going to direct us to where we're going
we're going back where you were for that
uh the first two hours of the day
georgetown
yeah daniella yeah i'll walk people
magneto's going to walk people over and
shoot
the red shirt and the amazing dance
with the panthers on and also she's our
emerging prompt specialist
come inside diana
[Applause]
specialist and she's really taken a lead
on
hemp production in new york state in
terms of being an on-farm presence and
uh helping to move the industry forward
uh thank her she put a lot of work into
this today in addition to larry smart's
lab and other people
and she would love to learn about what
you're growing and how you're growing
and she actually is an influencer she
actually has a good twitter handle
kanabakana
on twitter and she's got a good twitter
feed thank you
thank you let's eat lunch
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu